اذا شهران ونصف مرات من عمري الاحتجاجات
الايرانيه لكن ما شغل الايرانيين مؤخرا
كان من اطلق عليه لقب طفل العمامه المراهق
ارشيا امام جوليزادا البالغ من العمر 16
عاما اعتقله الامن لعشره ايام بتهمه اسقاط
عمامه احد رجال الدين
افرجها عن الفتاه لاحقا ولكن لم يمر يومان
على اطلاق سراحه حتى انتحر بحسب ما افاد
المجلس التنسيقي للمعلمين الايرانيين يوم
الاثنين اتهم مناسبون على مواقع التواصل
قوات الامن بتعذيب المراهق بشتى انواع
التعذيب خلال اعتقاله ما دفعه لاحقا
للانتحار بينما افاد مصدر مقرب من اسره
ارشيا لشبكه ايران انترناشونال ان قوه
الامن اقتحمت منزل العائله بعد فتره وجيزه
من الحادثه
وهددوها اذا ما تحدثت عن اي تعذيب عن اي
ترهيب تعرض له قبل وفاته يوم امس وري
ارشيه ترى في مدينته جلفا بمحافظه
اذربيجان الشرقيه شمال غرب البلاد
[موسيقى]
صندوق الامم المتحده للطفوله
الايرانيه ما ادى الى مقتل اكثر من 60
طفلا منذ بدء الاحتجاجات في منتصف سبتمبر
الماضي كما عبرت المنظمه الدوليه عن قلقها
البالغ حيل استمرار عمليات الذهب والتفتيش
التي تجري في بعض البدائس وقالت يونس ان
المدارس يجب ان تكون دائما اماكن امنه
للاطفال كررت يونسيف مطالبه الامين العام
للامم المتحده لقوات الامن الايرانيه
بالامتناع عن استخدام القوه غير الضروريه
او غير المتناسبه وخاصه عندما يتعلق الامر
بالاطفال والمراهقين سبق للامم المتحده
وان اعلنت انها نقلت مخاوفها مباشره الى
السلطات في ايران منذ وقوع الحالات الاولى
لضحايا الاطفال ردا على الاحتجاجات
وذكرت منظمه ايران بانها طرف في اتفاقيه
حقوق الطفل وعليها ان تلتزم احترام وتطبيق
حقوقهم في الحياه وحريه الفكر والتجمع
السلمي بصرف النظر عن هويتهم او مكان
وجودهم